[Music]
hey guys so what happens to you when you
stop smoking cigarettes well some people
out there believe that the effects of
smoking is irreversible but is that true
well no not entirely so what really
happens to us when we stop smoking well
that's what we're going to talk about in
this video so let's get to it mistakes
by mistakes make you strong now just
very quick if it's your first time here
on my channel i'm daniel and welcome to
d LM model lifestyle subscriber and also
to live that notification belt so you
won't miss any of the next videos
now when you stop smoking we all know
that there's a lot of good effects like
for example your teeth is not gonna be
so yellow anymore and also you're not
gonna smell that bad and the risk of
cancer is gonna lower we all know that
but what really happens to us when we
stop smoking well let's start at the
beginning let's start a day one when you
quit smoking
all right there's the first day when you
quit smoking and so the nicotine levels
in your bloodstream started to drop and
you've also lowered your risk of heart
attack why because smoking causes the
reactive constriction of blood vessels
in your body so when you stop smoking
the constriction will also start to
cease and cause lower blood pressure
pulse rate and your body's normal
temperature will also start to return to
normal and it's also interesting that
just after eight hours since you quit
smoking oxygen already start to reach
your cells and tissues
I need to know that your nicotine
withdrawal symptoms will be at its worst
within the first two the third day so
just try to push through it but the cool
thing is they look in the first three
days your taste and smell receptors will
also start to return to normal so you
can expect that your food is already
going to taste better
and in this short period of time you're
also going to be able to start to
breathe a lot easier because the
bronchial tube started to open more in
your lungs and your lung capacity to
fill up with air also increases and
within two weeks
those strong withdrawal symptoms that
you have they're going to start to
decrease a lot so it's going to be a lot
easier for you to stop smoking
permanently and in this time circulation
and oxygenation also improves a lot so
you can start to breathe a lot more
easier than you used to study showed
that your lung function increases as
much as thirty percent and that is just
two weeks after you've quit smoking
after just one month of quitting smoking
you start to realize that many of your
smoke related symptoms like congestion
sinus and shortness of breath the
creased a lot another huge thing
happening this time the fibers in your
lungs that help your lungs to stay
healthy start to grow back our bodies
are just amazing the human body is
always trying to heal itself to prepare
itself while we usually just break it
out with stupid things like smoking now
these fibers that start to grow back
they help you to reduce mucus buildup
and protect you against infections and
then at around a month and a half you
will draw symptoms like anger anxiety
depression insomnia and difficulty
concentrating will start to disappear a
woman can also improve her fertility and
the risk that her baby will be born
prematurely and your body's overall
energy also starts to improve a lot
now at around one year you're starting
to realize just how much money you've
saved since you quit smoking but apart
from that your lungs it's gonna be a lot
stronger in capacity and in functioning
as well and then after three years the
risk of heart attack lowers to normal
meaning is the same as somebody who's
never smoked in their life and then
after five years since she stopped
smoking the risk of lung cancer lowered
to 50%
[Music]
and then after ten years the risk of
dying to lung cancer then is the same as
somebody who never smoked so it means
that you have healthy cells again you're
back to normal
and also other smoking-related cancers
like cancers of the mouth esophagus
bladder kidneys and pancreas also goes
down so if you're still smoking it's
time to stop it's time to quit do it for
yourself do it for your family and
remember smoking cigarettes is like
paying money to have your life cut
shorter doesn't really make sense anyway
if you liked this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe and I'll see you in the
next video
sure
[Music]